this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week we did our best to break Jonathan's
brain for April Fool's Day and with some
very special cursed guns from hot dogs
Horseshoes and Hand Grenades this is a
horrible negative space between the
barrel and the and the frame of the
Glock oh makes me almost physically sick
this is bad and you should feel bad let
us know what other games or guns you'd
like to see Jonathan break down and make
sure to subscribe for more of this kind
of content on the channel including our
show Loadout which takes an in-depth
look at some of the most iconic firearms
in gaming right happy April Fool's Day
Jonathan
well that's a that's a bit disturbing
um one of these sort of a super
truncated barrel and a truncated
receiver as well and in a a very low
power cartridge so you could design a a
tiny tiny Uzi this is the micro Uzi I'm
drawing some of you know but it's in
nine millimeter I'm slightly confused by
the magazine design as well as to why it
needs to be so Broad in the base and
then narrowing to the overall length of
the 25 ACP I think it was cartridge I
might be missing something there my my
brain is already slightly fried by that
a crazy gun I think um Ian from
forgotten weapons would probably call
that a small angry bees
so this is a scaled down Mosin now there
are reduced scale rifles of All Sorts
there's also a really quite fascinating
historical precedent for this I think
the idea was to encourage
um I guess warlike Offspring and so you
do see these perfectly beautifully made
by the same people usually scale late
19th century rifle but it's kind of
weird because until you're holding them
you don't appreciate how small they are
this is essentially a child size rifle
oh no
[Music]
that's it okay right
well heresy more MP5 heresy clutch this
what this real one tight as I uh process
the pump action MP5 now this is gonna
cause I suspect this is going to
precipitate some comments of a certain
nature regardless of what I say about it
so on the one hand
it's quite clever there's no reason why
it wouldn't work and if you're going to
do it you probably want to make a bunker
out of the handguard from the mp5sd I
don't know uh maybe a cut down I God I
can't believe I'm thinking about how to
do this but probably the MP5K vertical 4
grip handguard would make the most sense
for a pump action MP5 I don't know
just not the same is it
foreign
yeah I definitely definitely cursed
design there but I have been shown
inspiration for this one pretty pretty
closely modeled after a real craft
produced firearm and the game does a
good job of modeling it as it does with
all of its guns actually the the finish
a lot of these improvised designs well
sorry craft produced designs not
technically improvised they do not
typically get the privilege of a finish
so the bare metal tends to rust and we
see that here with the slightly
disgusting Sheen of uh erosion not a
happy design but needs must uh I guess
pause it there yes unfortunately I know
exactly what this is
um killing killing them softly I think
was the title
Dreadful film I thought that that's
that's a subjective opinion on them on
the movie itself quite a quite an
interesting plot point in terms of the
stupidly cut down sort of shotgun that
is replicated here with the front of the
cartridge cases sticking out of the the
cut down it's incredibly cut down
barrels I was laughing already because
I've seen like trying as I think you can
do in H3 VR barrels on a shotgun you can
flick it shut as you can with a real one
well the shorter the barrel gets the
less Mass there is up front and you
can't do that and certainly with one
this shot you can't do it so we saw the
table used as leverage to actually close
the the breach so let's see what it does
oh
there's excessive spread which you would
get point being The lethality is
definitely reduced because the velocity
of these pellets is way way low not an
effective weapon uh very funny to see it
in in use in the game especially with
the the running
they're wearing a force from from
these rounds to blow locks up a door
then it would be a highly convenient
breaching shotgun being so tiny but not
great not very safe because although
it's less less than uh little as you
would wish it speaks enough to blow your
fingers off so um not very safe not a
good idea
don't do it
what the heck is that
what
this thing is completely insane I mean
do I need to say anything about this
obviously not a good idea it wouldn't
work because there isn't enough support
for the cartridge case so the cartridge
case is going to burst and or shoot out
the back there isn't even any room to
install the round in the in the sort of
metal Loops that are supporting it in
front of the striker so it's not it's
not although it looks very very
practical and realistic it's not
something that would work in real life
it's gonna have probably just enough
support to blow up and frag your face
with bits of brass the bullet will go
down range for a short distance but the
fun of a sort of physics sandbox like
this especially in VR is of course you
can experiment with different ways of
using things
the gun smacked on the desk to fire it
which would of course function you would
definitely be able to initiate around
that way but uh even more problematic in
terms of the case exploding and then the
bullet probably still coming out with
some amount of force in the rough to
direction of your head so or it's
towards somebody else not not
recommended but you know on the plus
side it has a picatinny rail so you can
accessorize it with all sorts of
nonsense
uh
are you telling me that the front ring
of that cartridge support is dreaded
for an oil filter suppressor I mean I'm
curious to see how it works because
there's going to be a heck of a lot of
noise behind the knot breach let's see
okay
yeah that's that's far too quiet uh no
one's ever done this so I can't say for
sure but there's going to be a lot of
noise so it's going to make a big old
bang it's not going to make a any kind
of suppressed effect now the sliding
butt stock is a nice touch I mean maybe
it'll prevent you from taking too much
damage to the face can't help feeling I
should have a whiskey or something don't
even drink whiskey but uh I think I need
one for to see this one out
foreign
highly appropriate for this insane
Design This is technically plausible but
ill-advised I think it's safe to say the
color scheme is uh offensive trying to
maintain my composure slightly I think
case ejection would be problematic
because there's going to be a fair bit
of friction from the expanded case in
the chamber and it doesn't appear to be
an extractor it's going to be a fair bit
of a supposed to call it stiction inside
the chamber there at least of the
problems with this gun
foreign
that is hilarious I'm looking at this
thing naively thinking that it's uh just
one of these exotic skeletonized race
guns with an adult like on the face of
it this thing is this is a gun you could
build in terms of how it looks but I
should have realized it pivots open and
it takes another enormous cartridge in
this case it's a 20 millimeter cannon
shell and I don't think I need to tell
you to tell you that it would be
problematic to design a rifle of these
proportions the main reason I'm still
laughing is that it just atomizes the
target when it hits it which isn't at
all realistic uh it would just create a
20 millimeter size hole in the paper
carry on downrange defeat the Target
backstop and hit someone in the car park
Beyond or what happens to be behind
hopefully the range is underground in
this virtual environment uh and then the
thing that really broke me I think was
the site which is like something you'd
see on a Nerf gun with physical process
inside it no matter vacation
oh Lord I think I think this one's
broken me
mom come here
[Music]
this thing is insane
I am familiar with a series of YouTube
videos the uh guy behind the camera does
sort of Manual of arms or
drills with household items um I've seen
a couple of those and they are they are
good fun this is this is based on that
still laughing at the silly noises it
makes when you press the buttons
obviously it's a child's toy that's been
uh combined with with a sort of a
shotgun I guess what it's depicting is a
sort of segmented tube magazine and then
the gun is somehow loading each one of
those in turn like a normal tube fed
shotgun is I'm sure an engineer could
make it work in some way the weather
would look quite like this I don't know
I'm running out of steam on this thing
it's it's truly insane but
congratulations to all consent
yeah there we go
foreign
I've got to hand it to the uh
vocalizations
for the button presses that are I think
slightly funnier than the original
what what's broken me this time is
seeing this like I like
thinking of how real world physics would
work and thinking you know what's a game
you put this very very long gun down on
a narrow bench
in reality it would tip off the front
but obviously it won't do that and then
of course it does do that because this
game has physics this thing's completely
nuts Caster Troy style gold plated 1911
only it's automatic has an insanely long
slide and Barrel presumably as I'm sure
a lot of you know this would not
function because the the mass of the
slide is too great it would stop it
opening up the roundwood fire of course
but it would not cycle it probably
wouldn't even open what what you what
you've sort of done there is create a
blowback locked recoil operate recoil
not operated firearm
who knows it'd make a very good club uh
possibly golf
another absolutely insane gun it's a
pretty faithful well probably entirely
faithful I think if it looks at all
wrong it's just because it's
of the infamous calibri which for scale
purposes is this pig
no bigger than my palm
um well smaller my palm significantly
actually a completely pointless meme gun
from long ago you I'm sure you know all
about this battlefield one put it in the
game famously Andrew if you're watching
this hello so what they've done they've
scaled it up by a factor of I'm not
quite sure and turned the rounds into
grenade rounds of some kind instead of
the trigger we have a whole 1911 pistol
with some sort of weird barrel shroud
rail system on it the fitted here to
operate as a trigger of course in
reality this is basically solid steel
well yeah the various components of it
are solid steel perfectly operable
despite being very small and fiddly and
basically less than lethal scaled up to
that size it would have to be on a
wheeled Carriage to operate and you'd
need some kind of a crank system to draw
back the the slide again don't need me
to tell you this is completely Bonkers
in a way it's no less practical than
this for actual fighting purposes
well what a touching tribute to Saint
John of Browning this is with the Stars
and Stripes barrel and receiver it's an
M2 made it made portable I've no doubt
Dwayne Johnson could uh could actually
carry and use this to some extent
not super practical but compared to
everything else I've seen today this is
basically a working firearm what can I
say it's it's one of the most American
Guns I've ever seen and uh if you're
ever gonna use a gun as a bludgeon I
mean that that clearly did the job to
that poor Frankfurter
I'm not angry I'm just disappointed
that's the worst thing I've seen today
the only the comparison that comes to
mind is the scene in Mars Attacks where
the character where Sarah Jessica Parker
has her head attached to the body of a
dog and vice versa that's what this
feels like
this is more disturbing than that to me
the Glock slide on the Luger is just
depressing
the Lucas Barrel assembly and part of
the frame that's on the Glock frame is
just horrible because of the there's a
horrible negative space between the
barrel and the and the frame of the
Glock oh makes me almost physically sick
this is bad and you should feel bad
right well time to welcome a new member
of the emotional support weapon Siri uh
family to the to the series
um here's a proper Stan Mark II it's
it's a machine gun only a designer could
love very important historical design
and massively underrated in my view what
we have on the screen here is 762 rifle
cartridge machine gun collection I guess
scaled up version of it um so there's a
two-part bus stop to I guess to try and
mitigate recoil with some sort of
buffering uh which you'd need I mean
often people often say about uh straight
blowback designs which operate from this
position this appears to just be scaled
up so would it work uh it wouldn't work
well I think it's safe to say uh
ignoring the picatinny rail on the front
that's just insult to injury and the
magazine is somewhat interesting in that
it's basically just a massive 30 caliber
stand box mag that's been looped over
into a me snail drum configuration
uh could you make that work and push a
stack a column of cartridges around that
smaller loop as a double stack probably
not not without some feed problems I
don't know I wouldn't like to try it and
I don't recommend it oh
right those were the guns of I guess
April Fool's Day a somewhat traumatic
experience
you enjoyed it uh it's only made me
laugh before it made me despair so um as
always check out the Royal armories
YouTube channel uh but on Facebook or
Twitter and Instagram
um come and visit us here at the Museum
in Leeds or the one down on the south
coast at Fort Nelson or at the Tower of
London we have stuff at all three sites
um I will go away and recover and we'll
see you again next time